fermer that runs together friends
together let's run yet Nina has like 50
mosquito bites all on her but they like
your butt I'm gonna be on youtube's
adopt you are it doesn't look very
exciting Hayden if we get stung by crazy
she does your father hello everyone
happy weekend we were supposed to be
camping yeah today yeah but they they
said it was rained out yeah which
doesn't really make sense because we
haven't had a lot of rain and it's a
beautiful day but Hayden is off for the
weekend and we were supposed to have a
weekend to ourselves to go camping and
have fun so we are gonna spend the
weekend in the city doing some fun stuff
and thought we would take you along with
us it was Nina's idea yeah you want them
you want them to come along with us yeah
all right here we go
I
there you go breakfast
okay we are at are we
what are we doing here oh good this is
one of toronto's the largest farmers
market every saturday morning from nine
or eight in the morning till one in the
afternoon and we are a little bit late
it's like 1215 so we have four to five
minutes because I spend a long time with
the coffee Nina made she sent an email
since you want to go to check out some
farmers markets lose fear oh did I say
okay I don't remember ok remembers
everything ok mom let's go gigabyte
something in the best spot
that's okay we can try to make it fit if
it gets wish it in get something small
Nina went to the bathroom so I do what I
always do when it has the spare time
so next up is Kensington Market Nina
looks really little from this angle huh
come on the step huh you still look
pretty little Kenzie the market is
what's consumer market it's a it's a
piece for a lot of artists model like
fun stores artistic shops super active
in the summer and so you're gonna check
it out
roberto blake this is for you buddy it's
art of sculptures she would do that at
our place my sculptures in the yard very
welcome in and friendly
okay you said you're a hungry right did
you look across the street
class juice and simple
is there a blacks circular sign
check it off oh okay Lina's obsessed
with this game now
but she's serving big food to fake
people here is our lunch Nina can't see
it I'm feeling
watching out
no move on
you want to go rowing Paul's gonna ask
you the same thing pipes yeah Wow let's
decent there what are you doing babe how
come you're wearing pigs you get mms law
why can't you wear the dress in the best
bug you might be able to hear the
background music next up something
clears salsa on st. Claire so every year
is a big salsa party in Toronto where
the shut off one of the streets a main
street and it's all about salsa so we're
gonna go how's the phone
salsa
ok Facebook friends I accidentally tag
Jessica as Nina will have to show the
picture i was looking through it quickly
and then realized oh wait a minute Nina
called me out on it that's not your wife
that's Jessica what they're both the
same height that's pretty close yeah so
there you go so you have to forgive me
so we're starting to crash out I think a
little bit too much Sun dehydrated
dehydrated no hats yeah we're gonna go
home yeah a lot sooner okay
okay day two of our weekend adventure
how did we finish yesterday we came home
I started gardening you gardened you got
a lot of mosquito bites what did I do I
don't know I cleaned up like I cleaned
up a lot actually no yeah okay then we
played some league of legends yeah nimi
wanted to keep playing it's like past
midnight let's play another game let's
play another game but we went to bed
mm-hmm then I woke up this morning to
Nina watching my youtube channel because
she forgot to turn off the volume on her
phone so I I woke up I did I don't know
why I didn't turn off the media once it
only turned out the rink oh yeah well it
was nothing off so so I woke myself up
this morning that was fun and now we are
for some more adventures we are we going
I don't know mmm surprise but you asked
me to bring the bug spray first up prod
breakfast okay so what I've got plan is
we're gonna go to Hamilton which is
about an hour outside of Toronto and do
a nature hike through all the Hamilton
waterfalls Nia's going inside Tim
Hortons our favorite spot to get us some
breakfast while I figure out what we're
gonna do on this hiking trip
so this is kind of frustrating we drove
one hour over an hour we got lots of
traffic on the way I drove over one hour
and it's closed what is this so Hamilton
is famous for its a waterfall walks
already yeah so we're supposed to go on
a three and a half kilometre hike
through here okay and the scenic walk
with a bunch of past like five different
waterfalls at you yeah take pictures
ever Oh Sophie nice I know you like
nature ah sad ok next time it's a
beautiful day yeah what are we gonna do
I didn't know tricom we're gonna contact
your friends I don't know Nina has
friends who live in in Hamilton that we
don't see often because it's pretty far
so we're gonna see if we can connect
with them when life hands you lemons
what do you do you make lemonade we'll
continue on so we were driving and I
found this place and we discovered
something called the Dundas valley
conservation area and there's this red
trail here that we can walk around and
can't give you the waterfalls but works
fine see what happens
of course the best shoes to hike with
are my vibe from 52 shoes comfortable
alright so question for you guys we're
at a fork in the road this is a loop so
we can go left we can go right either
way we're gonna end up back here and
have to go back home for whatever reason
I always want to go right at a loop we
went right at the first loop I want to
go this way I wonder what that says
about me anyway I'm if that's insightful
where do you guys go you got a fork in
the road do the same thing each time I'm
curious let me know in the comments
where do you go you go left I go right I
always good laughing I always go right
what does that mean we have opposite
personality why do we go left this time
for you
you
so we're over halfway done and when I
really wanted to do with teen animal of
some kind some kind of wild animal we've
got flowers we've got butterflies there
were rumors that they were deer around
here the only wild animal I've seen so
far this one is the Nina Hana mess back
here but I see it every day so it's not
that wild anymore so we're gonna hunt
for more animals and see what we can
find I found an animal it's just a
squirrel do something squirrel you're on
YouTube you're gonna be a star soon give
her something special yeah nice jump
buddy yeah oh we finally made it back
was way longer than we thought we need
food we're hungry hangry we need water
Brina washroom Nina's not super happy
graduated high hydrating tired so we're
gonna stop by our friends place relax
and get water first and then relax okay
okay so we made it back home what's the
summary we went to our friends place
yeah we had some water yeah you got to
go to the bathroom we relaxed yeah we
got a lot of show-and-tell with the kids
yeah you saw your sticker yes Nina got a
sicker I got a sick a tooth I was
unicorn Nina got Nina gotten tinkerbell
think about mine fell off cuz of the
sweat then we went to mcdonalds I know
you're crazy craving mcdonalds we're
supposed to be doing healthy stuff but I
got a big mac combo and Nina got a
quarter pounder combo extra pickles for
both of us and then we drove home and we
we went first or very quiet because we
were just hey shoving the food in our
face and then we're both happy and then
we're both be required again because the
food made us sleepy and so now we're
gonna go what cleanup have a shower I
have to make a playlist we got some
dancing
tonight makes a chili for dinner and
that's it so did a good weekend mm-hmm
okay thank you so thank you for joining
us on our weekend what else do you have
that's it continue to believe and we'll
see you soon bye